okay so you're gonna say dressed or you
want to see how sweet and amazing this
body is yeah hey lad Bible
I'm Jason Bateman I'm here with Sharon
Horgan hi that's her we're gonna paint
each other sweet tender amazing bodies
it seems sweet and tender and amazing
although I haven't seen it she's offered
to show it right but today we're gonna
paint it okay so you're gonna say
dressed you want to see how sweet and
amazing this body is yeah it's hard to
make a fresh color with green and blues
this just started great okay
I'm starting with your amazing beautiful
lovely I haven't looked at you once I'm
about to take this off the rails and
make you cross-eyed
really really up your nose I think
considering I was brought up in a turkey
farm that's really thought yeah that is
true
you're the killer Turkey I mean they're
pretty hard to kill it's pretty hard to
break a Turkey's neck is that true yeah
yeah how is it done well you kind of
pretend this is a turkey okay so if this
is a turkey it would be for the turkey
upside down you hang the Tang the turkey
upside down and its feet go into a
little sort of to little slot yeah
you get your fingers and you wrap them
around the turkeys neck yeah straight
down why don't you just grab it by the
face and pull down like that why do you
have to do a V with the fingers because
you can't just grab it by its face Adam
cuz that was sure that could be unkind
you look you just need to do the fingers
there start screaming at me that's how
you do it
you only worked with dead birds only
worked with dead birds yeah what did
your folks do I didn't do a lot of
animal killing in my house have you ever
thought about each other in a kid before
what this is La Vie Bible
I mean before before I met you I would
have thought about you naked but not now
if not know where it would be weird
would you like to see my interpretation
of your beauty
[Music]
it's beautiful isn't it way I have a
kind of just pair of lungs in the middle
of my face para testicle but I think
you're one is you're more likely to see
it in a gallery it has a kind of
Basquiat kind of feel we like to see
this in a kindergarten Oh joking that's
class thanks for sharing with us why do
I look like Richard Nixon you [ __ ]
[Music]